>> So after much deliberation I decided I would define creativity simply as
anything that produces an non-obvious, desirable product.
I think that we have to have to sort of output for creativity in order for
it to be actually be identifiable as creativity. I think that the output has to
actually be wanted in some way. Doing something that no one wants is
not necessarily creative. I think the output has to actually be desirable in
some way, and it also has to be something non-obvious. Doing the obvious answer
is not a very creative solution. If I'm propping open a door and
I use a chair, it's a slightly more creative solution to that problem.
Thank you David. Or course everyone's answer to this question may differ. For
example, some people may not put the word product here.
It's not clear that the result of creativity is necessarily a product.
Some people do not put the word desirable there because sometimes creativity may
not result from some initial desire. Let us carry on this discussion of
what is creativity on the forum. Feel free to add your own notions.